とても急なのですが
今から引っ越ししますまあいろんな映画引越しするんですけどもまぁ一番乗りはですね
ちょっと
人が僕の湯によく来るんですよ最近ねキャベツに来て照れるじゃダメだダメだ
来るか来ちゃダメだぞ町と加工し前に歩いているときにあったりしずるが全然嬉しい
喋ってですねしてうれしいんですけども
あっ作り
ず家に来られると困るんですよ次に来るとはやっぱり寝ちゃうので見た人の家に勝手に
入っちゃダメだぞ
生活で引越しですそういう家はちょっとまだ服を選んで着ているので引っ越します
よしん
私は採用したよ行くよね
お日様あああよ難しい重いですよ
いやーやっひーよっ
よああいやあああっ
usa ああああ
ああああああ
よくある通り
にもうちょっとで終わります例えば夜の
4ぐらいです
入って勇気でなんとか部屋の掃除が終わりました
6時間外でも絶対片付いたんでまぁこんなもんだろうと思いますよ
実は見ての通り1回だったんですよ難しいね
なんやかんや
約1年ですね約1でここに住んでていろんなことがあったんですけれども
今回ばかりはん
どうしようもなかったと引っ越しもして僕のことを応援してくれる人はとても嬉しくて
こともありがたいと思ってるんですけども
直接家に来られるということを恐怖にかられて出れなかった時とかもあったんであまり
ネグリあり人の家にいくっていうのはちょっと良くないかなって思います
みんな気をつけろよ
はん
はぁはぁん1
ああああああああ
いっ